thank you
[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are
indeed very careful boys and today we're
talking about how Bart bought big socks
they were so [ __ ] big dude so like
this time I tried the opposite technique
of what I saw crazy so last time I
looked at the medium I grabbed it like
this this time I looked at it and I
grabbed it like this and then the socks
were in the wrong that's why we got 20
000 views and not like half a million
like we used to yeah we thought that was
gonna be a big video by the way why are
you enabling this I thought it was
interesting though no today we are
talking about indeed our goals for two
thousand oh I was actually disappointed
for a second
say Goals
zoom in on that stick I wanna learn how
to do that that's a cool sound like two
jokes he's in pain dude
I did that for 2022. what are your goals
Mr Money guy yeah what's up money bags
winning [ __ ] winning getting getting
revenge on this [ __ ] dubs dude really
my Corners want revenge yeah we want
revenge do you have a do you like have
it written down is like on a whiteboard
or anything or are you just DCA all my
sick ass positions
baby what else are you gonna do I
brought my stuff today so we can sash
during lunch any other any other goals
um You probably
uh no
[Laughter]
all right I'm off the top of my head
well you're asking so I was like maybe
you got some
um what do you guys got
you go Anthony you probably think about
this [ __ ] New Year's resolution not
really you look like a goldfish yeah
Gold's good because I take all of
everybody in this room like the type of
people that goes man that would be dope
and you just [ __ ] do it like tomorrow
or like that minute you just start
writing out [ __ ] and you just [ __ ] do
it that's right a little bit but I do do
a little bit of New Year's resolution
because sometimes you have so many
that you kind of have to prioritize a
little bit yeah that's right and then so
like sometimes I'll be like I think this
one's kind of important yeah maybe I
should make that like to the top in
2020. that's true because sometimes I'm
like man I'm gonna eat a prime rib this
week
that goes to it takes too much time it's
good goals it's too hard yeah
unattainable I did wake up this morning
and hella relate Ryan posted today about
his keytar oh uh and that's also where
I've been this year too I've been
talking with Nina about it I was just uh
last year I didn't create a lot for
myself I did a lot of like work dance uh
I thought you're gonna be a Guitar Star
me too key star you'll get that literal
I thought he was gonna buy one I was
like dude I've been waiting to [ __ ]
just ask if I buy your used one
um no just uh just getting back to a
place where I'm creating for myself for
fun or for or for like fans and stuff
like that versus like for work or for
artists or for campaigns and clients and
corporations or whatever the freak you
know yeah just like no incentive do the
Arts yeah like help corporations that's
what you do Hub corporations absolutely
yeah help the man last year this year I
want to you know help myself
but uh but but I also I also feel like
you know uh I got in my own head you
know as a as an artist like just seeing
things like social media and just like
not really wanting to jump honestly I
think Instagram has been like annoying
in my life lately you know what I mean
just you said that yesterday yeah you're
really a hater now yeah it's just been
uh one of those I feel like I go through
seasons is all you know what I mean
there's times where I like I'm down for
social media I respect the hustle I'm
like you know I kind of like enjoy yeah
you know the interaction with people uh
but just this past last year I I've been
more off of it I've just been more like
um how come stuck in it in ways that
don't make me feel productive
uh or titties on your explore page
because I don't dude you should see mine
because you can get stuck there you get
stuck this for a long time I got little
people on my explore page that's for
sure
um should I should I edit that out no no
leave it we're it's already known that's
your New Year's resolution so we got to
keep in there oh yeah yeah so I got to
clean out my explore page so it's like
regular people again oh should I edit
that okay yeah
[Laughter]
Joe Legend
why is it offensive to be like
that's so offensive but not ordinary
ordinary regular that's the same [ __ ]
John Legend didn't make it that'd be
kind of crazy huh his name's Legend it's
like oh [ __ ] yeah that's kind of setting
a high bar that's a high bar yeah or
it's called manifesting because you
named yourself that like you self
profosifies that's why I'm wearing money
I'm wearing money I like it I like it I
need to get a money suit well what if
all of those hundreds just added up to
being 2
153 and I'm like wow I made two thousand
two hundred fifty dollars is awesome
because all those hundreds of you
actually counted it's probably about 2
000. I I see it it's closer to four
thousand okay yeah okay I go off you
didn't count the pants yeah you count
the pants oh [ __ ] that definitely looks
like at least five thousand okay I see
money is mostly worthless anyway it's
just about getting positions baby
lowering my dollar costume
you guys want to hear some boring [ __ ]
yeah let's hear yours he's gonna to buy
actual socks that fit this year no I
have a so like I think I've
just throughout the the years of doing
social media and like business and like
pursuing passions and stuff I realized
like a lot of the stuff I did was more
based off of like my interests and
feelings and never really playing the
game I think even with like JK that's
why we've kind of like had like a pretty
steady growth we've never had
exponential growth or exponential crash
because we've always just kind of been
like [ __ ] the algorithm I know people
have new methods now but we're just
going to keep making the content that we
really like and I think I I like pretty
much live my life like that and this
year I was like maybe I should try to
like play the game and the things that
I'm actually in so for example with like
bottle Brigade we always just create
products that we liked rather than
looking at data and go oh how do we 10
here 10 here 10 here and then overall
like the company can grow year over year
which is like what most business people
do versus the other way around it's like
oh you know what be [ __ ] sick we just
make a sick ass protein there's a bunch
of one-offs that don't really kind of
connect and like my whole life even my
own fitness journey is kind of like that
versus like
what should I do as an athlete if I'm
going to be an athlete like do I just
choose random Endeavors or do I do
something that has like quarterly things
that build to like a big annual thing at
the end so like um we actually have like
goals for like barbell and stuff that we
actually want to accomplish and then
almost going from like a more I guess
um more business responsible way instead
of just doing the fun [ __ ] like setting
little goals how to get there and even
with my fitness like really trying to
like
take it in a way where it's um
like being what's better for the sport
versus me being fat and the skinny and
fat and skinny like [ __ ] like that
that's good too though yeah I think so
well I don't know I just feel like I've
done that for so long it feels like when
I zoom out it's just a constant Plateau
versus like if I actually did the things
that got incrementally better it would
it would be like that versus like that I
like the ascending quarterly goals and
then like having a big thing at the end
and like incrementally getting better
and I I can't wait for you to bring that
to JK
[Laughter]
are so busy dude I think the next year
for sure I don't know about this year
yeah yeah not this year not this year
and the other one is uh you know what I
learned I'm absolutely crushing it in my
other businesses but here we'll do this
later
yeah and uh the other name dropping the
other one is um is it's a big goal of
ours in terms of family like that family
aspect to have Gob a stay-at-home mom so
we're really trying to like figure out
finances in a way to make that happen
and that's kind of like the biggest I
guess North Star it might it might
in our list of priorities oh so that's
like almost like every that's like
what's guiding all my decisions you know
like okay what are we gonna do what can
we do to make it we're joking be more
stay-at-home mom be with Tyco more
um probably if JK was more successful
maybe
can we Circle back to that
[Laughter]
usually the word [ __ ] comes out of your
mouth after that
I noticed that when I looked at your
eyeballs and I was like [ __ ] like
crushes so we get so many views with him
on just kidding news he could be a nude
kids host for JK news oh yeah dude just
child work you know we need child
laborers
honestly but man better than 80 of our
videos that's true let's be honest we
always talk about [ __ ] anyway oh and
also rekindling stuff with my mom that's
because we've talked about how there's a
new chapter a great start so I'm like
actually I'm like okay cool like there's
that trauma that we really talked about
I want to actively and not just
passively go I'll call me my mom a
little bit better but I want to like
actually get to the point where like
where my mom wants me and her to be like
this I'm like I think we can do that and
we have enough time to do it so that'd
be pretty cool it just it just sounds
like to me like you were
um just first chasing your curiosity and
enjoying life for yourself but then now
you're just thinking long term and and
now because your role of a father and
like family man is like the priority all
your goals are now set toward that
that's that's kind of what it seems like
rather than just like I was [ __ ] up
just exploring and being an artist
um a little bit because I also I think
all the advice that I've heard
throughout the years I've ignored all of
it you know what I mean so it's like
it's a little bit of like
a lot of people are right
as long as you gotta go through yourself
right yeah yeah yeah
I get that I just remember you sitting
there [ __ ] telling Graham Stefan
about your your how you're spending
every month and that guy is about to
have a [ __ ] heart attack oh dude yeah
let's look at our monthly income
five percent to food five percent to the
least like he's very calculated right
like he breaks down people he goes how
did how did JK do it I'm like we got a
million dollar deal and we spent half of
it on building a studio and he goes did
you guys know what the ROI was on that
no it was fun and he just see his eyes
go like
it was the best yeah we like I think you
took a year off his life just having
that
he's probably still thinking about it
today like that that Fitness star
that bodybuilder we had the other day
wow it wakes up a little bit
probably makes like 200 G's a month
and this [ __ ] caps his food you
know he's like I'm not gonna spend like
more than like a grand or two grand a
month on my groceries or whatever that's
extremely smart and I'm like
and he makes he doesn't he could
actually not even think about it you
know what I mean yeah two grand on
groceries but then he's like but he's
like oh that's how people keep their
money I guess people keep track of it
laughs
who else wants to go go ahead man oh you
reminded me though I do want to I do
want to build a casita yeah in my
backyard
I thought you're gonna make a crypto
Casino that's so sick that would have
been cool oh well we were going to yeah
tell me about your Casita that's so cool
yeah so so me and Nikki were thinking
because like my folks are getting up
there you know they're about to die soon
um but I know it feels like yeah it's
weird your side or Nikki's side both but
but Nikki's parents are younger than
mine like by like almost 10 years oh
yeah they're almost closer to my age
yeah yeah oh and you got you got that
whole space in the back yeah huge
backyard yeah so we're like yeah we'll
um well because my sister was talking
about adding on to her place and then
like if need be we would have a place
for my parents too so it's like wouldn't
be too much on my sister wouldn't you
know UPS the property about exactly
exactly so yeah we're definitely gonna
do that we're looking at doing that this
year [ __ ] yeah cool yeah buddy let's go
dude that's sick
you're gonna add a space A little yeah
it's like a
you've seen it's like I've got a bedroom
it's got a shower oh yeah yeah yeah they
call it like a that's right like a
mother-in-law's or something right yeah
and the strategy they call it pretty
much a bird strategy or you add it and
then now you increase the square footage
and then you get it reappraised and then
you can cash out refi dude he's been
saying I've been watching a lot of this
we're trying to be a dad because you're
trying to do the same [ __ ] too right yep
I'm trying to do more I'm trying to take
the next level
real estate that's the only way we could
bring in more money so so we can switch
Geo and tackles rules
that's the tough part though I think a
lot of us are artists first yeah and
then and then we learn business the
other way whereas a lot of the guys they
were like business first and then
they're like how do I make the art make
me money you know like like Graham stuff
is probably really good at editing
videos now he's probably good even
speaking on camera but he probably had a
business approach and then he learned
the skill set of making a video after
versus us we're like let's make videos
and then we're like oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] 44. should probably learned how
to make some money
honestly it's good though because if you
get them to make money and who started
too because they like yeah yeah yeah and
that's the wrong way to start yeah and
also a lot of our friends that are kind
of Graham Stephanie like they look at us
and go [ __ ] you guys had so much fun and
I don't have the same memories that's
true trade-offs right
what up dude we went to the Trump Tower
[Laughter]
but at the same time we don't open our
bank account you see overdraft fees and
like with those memories
those memories had nothing to do with JK
they had
to with [ __ ] Luna God damn it that
was fun though
hey those memories though memories baby
the highs were great scared paint is
sometimes real fun it is God damn
[Laughter]
we'll be back [ __ ] what are
some of yours I feel like you're [ __ ]
a level-headed [ __ ] I think for
me this year is um just kind of doubling
down on whatever I'm doing a little bit
more like for instance like with my own
business my personal training coaching
business
marketing myself more and doing not
reflecting maybe yeah that would be good
that's a form of marketing yeah because
they need personal training get that guy
yeah yeah yeah no no no no I'm not that
good I'm not that good with something
yesterday like like thankfully I've been
lucky enough to be able to survive
without having to do like that much
marketing and I've been able to get
clients and be very thankful with that
which is awesome but like most of my
clients that I get are like referral
base and it's like local so it's great
but like if I want to get to where I
want to be and make them the income that
I want I have to start like putting
myself out there a little bit more doing
more marketing and I think for the past
couple years of just learning how to
like not be a complete overthinker and
not be so much of a self-doubter and
like the things that I do and really
diving in and really trusting myself and
making sure that like you know I put
myself out there more and not be like
afraid of the repercussions you know so
I think this is the year that I need to
start doing that a lot more so I think
the first step is you know marketing
more getting on my systems having my
systems in play already so it's just uh
building on that so that's what I think
I'm trying to do this year what dude
just in case yeah that's good yeah yeah
you're feeling a little vulnerable there
didn't you yeah man [ __ ] you dude get
out of here get off me you guys are you
guys are crowding me dude markings
talking about yourself hard it's okay
you can talk about yourself here shut up
man the stuff that you have been
promoting that we've been like reposting
and stuff is dope man like I really
support you [ __ ] putting yourself out
there because I know that you're [ __ ]
really skilled and really intelligent
with what you do oh I appreciate that
man I know nobody could have made David
skinny except you that's true I think I
think I think it was the right time at
the right time
I think that was Far Cry Cheney with the
party party got found with him
dude David has a hold on people David
will come train with you and take you to
lunch there there'll be something
instead of training yeah dude they would
do that all the time people like hey I'm
30 minutes late you just want to get
lunch and I'd be like okay I show up at
his place to write and he's like let's
go eat and I'm like and then we go eat
for two hours I'm talking about [ __ ]
I have the best conversations but it
just and you leave and you're like I
didn't get [ __ ] done bro and he's like
we'll do it next time we'll do it next
time dude he's such a good hang he's
such a good hanger it's hard to get work
done with David but yo you're gonna find
the best restaurants though honestly me
and Tiff were talking about this other
day any restaurant that he recommends is
undefeated like no matter what it's like
10 out of 10. well and he's like you're
a [ __ ] tour guide while you're there
yeah he like knows the people and [ __ ]
I'm like getting on my history of it I'm
like have you ever been to the city
before and he's like he's like I was
just here yesterday or something and
it's like what the [ __ ] they're all like
hello David hello yes good he's like so
you got to try this you gotta try this
bro they're like he's here he's here are
20 for the year come on
what you got going
yeah that's me and David
what I really want to
uh these are all boring but uh one of
them is I want to get good at Bondo like
I want to go yeah wait like on cars yeah
I want to get good I want to get good at
like a dent repair oh it's nice you'll
be watching Chris fix and [ __ ] oh yeah
oh my God those videos are so addictive
it's really good yeah but I I just have
a lot of like stuff like that that I
kind of have to do yeah like um and a
lot of good projects that I can you know
why not get good at it rather than just
keep paying people to like you know
that's cool all right because I learned
how to do like last year I learned how
to do carpeting like in homes
I was like dude it can't be that
freaking hard to learn you gotta have
knee pads though too right yeah well
yeah kind of hit them with the [ __ ]
thing yeah you have it's a knee kicker
yeah you like stuff it into the side
yeah I've seen them people work yeah and
it kind of makes you want to get better
at things like that and then um and then
another thing I just want to have a
dedicated like weekly uh session for
dancers because we we had something like
that last year
um but uh the studio that we were
running out of closed down so you have
to stop but we just want to do like a
dedicated Open session for people to
just come to it just like young people
to come and just learn stuff but in the
environment of not being a class but
just being like the way that we learned
like a jam session yeah person to person
like you go up and go hey how do you do
that and then the rule is that if you're
if you're like a what's it called like
if you're like a really good dancer and
you come the rules like oh you don't
have to pay but if someone asks for help
you have to help them okay that's so
cool yeah that's the system that we want
to run and uh can I bring a kid can I
bring a baby not like an actual kid
crying spinning baby yeah no my my
nephew's just got into
um break dancing and yeah I think he's
like 10 now or some [ __ ] yeah because
like in my head I always felt like that
was the best exposure to like loving it
and learning it correctly which is
structure yeah just be in the
environment of it no pressure you could
sit there and watch you can join in you
can ask but then the main thing is that
like I've never been at a practice where
the system was like hey cool guy you
have to help him like that's really cool
like it might be so structured yeah
because and that's and to be honest
that's how it felt when I was starting
it it felt like people I could just walk
up and ask a person and they would just
go yeah like this and they were just
nice when I first started it definitely
took me like three four months before I
could go up to the cool guy to ask for
more yeah exactly yeah you're just in
the corner just trying your best so it's
nice to gather like leaders of of Our
Generation that are are gonna be aware
of that and go like hey man like it
looks like you're trying this like let
me give you some I'm going to your
session but I'm paying so I could just
get the hell that's stupid you already
know how to do everything we went we
went to random events and there were so
many people that just helped before we
were joking yeah yeah like known and
[ __ ] like they're just like nice yeah
like the machine gun Funk guys like
um the pop and Chuck remember popping
Truck Yeah he was at the park should I
rename the homeless Chuck but same thing
oh he's homeless now it was Chuck he
looked like it
go inside yeah
that's that's tight man yeah it's gonna
be good for the community I'm sure and
then next year you can learn how to do
ceiling fans
dude I actually have a ceiling fan I
haven't installed it I have it for like
a year dude you are so interesting I
want to learn but he's such an
interesting person like are you gonna
learn to not just Bondo but also the
paint process and clear coat and all
that I think I'm gonna just go up to
primer because like I I think I'm gonna
wreck it a lot I'm gonna mess up a ton
because the only way to know is to like
get the you know have the sanding done
put the primer on stand back and go oh
[ __ ] but I have to buy a [ __ ] up car
for like 500 bucks oh my van is like
crazy to crap it and it's a perfect
project yeah did you do the carpet in
your van I did it I didn't I did the
wood and then I did uh some of the trim
but not the not the actual post but you
know how to do it
I know I do it badly dude you're so
handy very handy person I know how to do
everything like that very shitty but
this year I want to like get proficient
enough to like where someone can't tell
if I paid for it or not my favorite
thing is knowing exactly how to do it
and then I have something else do it for
me
nothing I ordered this year so um I me
and Nikki won the Christmas lights
competition in our neighborhood congrats
did you put it up yourself I did oh
that's big boy that's a big boy big was
your lights it was a show [ __ ]
it was a show
so I want to crush my neighbors again
this year
defend the title because as soon as we
should make a belt bro dude I'm gonna
make a belt that's a great idea I'm
gonna make a holiday lights Christmas
they gave us this like placard that they
put in our yard for a couple days like
to show everyone that we [ __ ] won and
then me and Nikki put like a [ __ ]
outdoor light on it so everyone had to
look at it especially my neighbors but
then my neighbors were all talking [ __ ]
to me about how they're going to go for
the title next year so I gotta [ __ ]
defend the title
start like dude in September I remember
buying I'm gonna be going to Costco I'm
going to [ __ ] Amazon buying up all
their Christmas [ __ ]
buy all of it so they can't buy anything
I want to make my house look like
Christmas Vacation dude it's gonna be
insane guys let's see what you conjure
up dude dude they're gonna have to get a
new nuclear power plant in [ __ ]
Nevada
[Laughter]
right because I talked so much [ __ ] I
have to bring it you're gonna wreck the
grid man my next door neighbor is like
do dude I'm coming next year for that
I'm like do you or you should kill
yourself now
or you don't put yourself as Shameless
snow into his yard every day the best
thing is we won one Nikki was doing her
twitch stream or poker stream yeah and
my neighbors were watching yeah because
they play poker too and and we were like
we [ __ ] won and we're like what are
you gonna do okay what are you gonna
[ __ ] do about it Katie and then she's
that's when she found out that she lost
and guess what we want what a candle
no I mean like who who judges the other
neighbors just judge it yeah the name
and we won for our street we didn't win
for like the whole Community that's the
goal that's the goal right it's like
that though you guys are you guys are
involved you go to all valid yeah all
right
do you have an equals jar I just want to
[ __ ] him feel rested bro I just finished
my one is Yeah by 2022 it just opened up
jumbee that was [ __ ] crazy yeah and I
got that open well if we if we moved JK
a couple hours earlier it'll get even
more sleep yep
[Music]
foreign
[Music]